okay today I'm going to talk to you
about phloem and xylem so phloem and
xylem adjust to different types of tube
that transport substances through our
plants so let's start off by looking at
phloem now all I'm going to do here is
draw a diagram of a phloem tube so what
I'm showing here is it's made of lots of
different cells which are joined end to
end so these cells are actually living
cells now between each cell we have
these little end walls so here we go
their end walls and within the end walls
their little pores so these little holes
here are called pores that allow
substances to travel through so we've
got lots of living cells laid end to end
like this now what's the point of the
phloem the whole purpose of the phloem
is to transport food substances for the
plant and that is normally in the for
sucrose the way I remember this is the
first sound from phloem transporting
food phloem food so as we can see the
little end was the end pause allow the
food to transport through the holes like
this now phloem is involved in the
movement of this these food substances
the name of the process is called
translocation so translocation can
either transport substances down or up
so when the plant photosynthesizes it
makes the food in the leaves when it's
first made it's in the form of glucose
but when it's transported it's in the
form of sucrose so then we could
transport by using translocation we can
either transport that up the plant if it
needs to go up or down the plan because
it might need these food substances for
storage or growth in a particular area
and this process requires energy this
process of translation
Asia's requires energy so see how we can
transport substances both up and down
now this is a little bit different from
the other type of tube we need to know
about called a xylem tube now xylem
tubes again there are lots of different
cells laid end to end but the difference
is well there's a few differences first
of all as eylem cells are not living
cells they are dead cells if we look at
the phloem tubes you can see that they
all have end walls if you look at the
xylem we could see that there are no end
walls at all so it's essentially a long
hollow tube made of lots of dead cells
late end to end
so one this there's several here you can
see three different ones I've shown here
okay now rather than transporting food
xylem transport water only but within
the water there are mineral ions which
are dissolved within the water now
unlike phloem tubes that can transport
substances both up and up and down
xylem only transfer transfer water up
the way I always think about design is
like a straw just sucking up in one
direction now if we have a look at our
plant here water is absorbed in the
roots so the xylem vessels transport
water up from the roots to the rest of
the plant can be for example to get it
to the leaves where water is needed for
photosynthesis now it's a similar word
to translocation but this process is
called transpiration and there's another
video I've done just about this process
that you can watch now the final thing
we need to know before you just move on
to our summary is the walls of this
island a strengthened by something
called lignin so lignin is a substance
which strengthens these walls and allow
it to operate as it does now what I've
done next is I've just put together a
table that will help us
kind of summarize the phloem and xylem
so first of all the flow and what does
it carry well it carries food in the
form of sucrose is it living or dead
phloem is living which direction can it
transport substances both up and down
what's the name of the process its
translocation and does it have end walls
yes so conversely if we were to look at
silent what does it carry water and
mineral ions which are dissolved within
the water is it living or dead cells
dead cells direction now remember the
xylem only transports the water up like
a straw the process is transpiration and
finally does it have any end walls the
answer is no that guy's is a nice
summary of xylem so it will phloem and
xylem thank you